ida has left more than one million
americans along the gulf coast without
power and parts of new orleans could be
in the dark for weeks at least four
people have died from the storm which
was the fifth strongest hurricane ever
to make landfall in the united states or
marvia franca is in bridge city just
outside of new orleans where crews have
been working around the clock omar good
morning
good morning this is one of the main
reasons why the power is out in new
orleans metro area this tower stood
about 400 feet tall not anymore ida's
winds tore it down and now hospitals
police departments and others are
running on generators and no one is sure
when the power will be back on
as hurricane item and its 150 mile per
hour winds crashed into louisiana's gulf
coast
the storm left almost as quickly as it
roared in taking much of the region's
electricity with it
the toppled utility poles and tangled
power lines in these pictures have more
than 25 thousand electricity workers in
louisiana scrambling to restore what
they can
but it's a big job more than two
thousand miles of transmission lines
went out of service along with 216 power
substations our 911 infrastructure right
now
is not operable
here is a big part of the problem this
massive electrical tower lying on its
side is responsible for shuttling power
across the mississippi and into new
orleans and its transmission lines are
now underwater
new orleans mayor latoya cantrell city
agencies have been out since daybreak
they're going block by block
neighborhood by neighborhood
and that includes some of the state's
most vulnerable dr mark klein is a
physician in chief at children's
hospital in new orleans it's still
running on generators he worries about
an uptick in covet cases among kids
because of the storm our concern now is
that if we congregate a lot of people in
closed spaces indoors in shelters for
example
we could reverse some of the gains that
we've made we really don't want to see
that happen
39 medical facilities are running on
generator power so they can keep on
providing care to their patients entergy
the power company says it's going to
take them at least four days just to do
a damage assessment so it could be weeks
before power is restored here tony it's
a long time omar thank you very much